JOSEPHINE DORADO: Hi everyone.
My name is Josephine Dorado.
I am the president of the
Fulbright Association's greater
New York chapter
here in New York.
And I'm happy to introduce our
panelists; Jennifer Wright,
the CEO of The Field, an artist
service organization, and Earl
Douglas, the executive director
of New York's chapter of Black
Rock Coalition, and Jeremy Xido,
the director of Death Metal
Angola, which we've
just finished seeing.
So I'll let you guys go
ahead introduce yourself
and a bit about
your organization.
Jennifer, if you could start?
JENNIFER WRIGHT: Sure, so
I'm the executive director
of The Field, which is an
arts service organization here
in New York.
And we work nationally
with about 1,400 artists
and companies a year
helping build their capacity
to make their art and
grow their careers.
We have 11 national and
international sites.
And actually Jeremy is part of
The Field for many years now.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: Yea, Field!
EARL DOUGLAS: Again, my
name is Earl Douglas.
I'm the executive
director for the New York
chapter of the Black
Rock Coalition.
We've been around since 1985.
It was co-founded by
a group of artists,
namely Vernon Reid,
guitarist of Living Colour,
Greg Tate, writer, journalist,
musician, Kona Mason,
she was an artist
representative.
And it was started as an
organization to really support
and advocate
musicians of color who
we're going outside of the box.
At that particular time, it
was you had to do R and B,
you had to do hip hop.
Anything in between
was verboten.
And we had a small army of
artists who were not doing that
and wanted to freely
express themselves
and wanted to go through
all the avenues afforded
to pretty much everyone
else the same way.
So they started to
the organization
as a partial advocacy group,
and it's evolved over the years
now that you can pretty
much make your own record.
You can go independent now.
So we really support
independent artists.
But the focus is still
supporting artists of color
who just want to openly express
themselves freely and openly
and without any
restrictions upon them.
JEREMY XIDO: And
I'm Jeremy Xido.
I'm the director of
Death Metal Angola.
My background however is
as a dancer and performer.
And I'm the co-director
of a performance and film
company called Cabula6, which
is based in part in New York
and part in Vienna.
And we do live performance
site-specific work, dance work,
and film work.
JOSEPHINE DORADO:
Thanks, so I also
want to add too that the New
York chapter of the Fulbright
has just this year launched
a new program called
the Fulbright alumnus in
residence program, which
incubates alumnus projects
that have to do with embodying
the mission of the
Fulbright which
is towards international
peace and understanding.
And we're happy to also announce
that Jeremy Xido is actually
our inaugural Fulbright
alumnus in residence.
[APPLAUSE]
JEREMY XIDO: Thank you.
It's awesome.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: So one
of the prevailing themes
of Death Metal Angola is very
much this idea of resilience,
of about communities facing
great adversity, whether that's
adversity through economic or
socioeconomic circumstances,
or natural disasters.
So within this sort of
prevailing theme of resilience,
what sort of role do you feel
like artists fulfill or can
leverage towards building
community recovery
and resilience?
JEREMY XIDO: Well,
I actually just
answered a question similar
to this yesterday for radio
in Germany.
I can speak just in terms of
what I think about the people
that I met in Angola
and my experience there.
A lot of people, when
they see the film,
they talk about what is the
power of this particular form
of music for this
particular group of people.
And a lot of times I've been
answering that, well, it's
a kind of music that can
withstand the stories that they
have to tell, that
there is something
almost journalistic in
the phantasmagoric lyrics,
et cetera, somehow are
related to a lived experience
and being able to
express trauma.
But I actually think,
in retrospect, I've
been thinking that it's just the
fact of having bands and just
the fact of having
a joint mission.
And being able to touch truth
together with other people
and to go for it and to create
a safe space in order to do that
is extremely healing.
And in part because
it allows you
to fight, to pick up pieces,
disagree with one another,
and negotiate,
which are all things
that a lot of the people in
this film, at least socially,
the country has lost
the ability to do over
the course of 40 years
of near constant warfare.
And when I see
them, it's not just
about cathartic
release and screaming.
It's actually about the
constructive process
of building an organization and
having to stick with it, partly
through ambition, partly
through concerts that come up.
And that is,
essentially, for me when
I think about it, the
main purpose of art,
as a social phenomenon.
EARL DOUGLAS: I saw the film.
And there was parts of
the movie that as-- I've
been part of the
BRC for 25 years.
And there were little bits of
our experience in that movie.
Just getting together
is the hardest thing,
the community aspects of it.
And I think that was a key part.
It was just like getting
everyone together and just
having, OK, you feel this way.
I feel this way.
You feel this way.
Let's get together and just
turn whatever pain we have,
whatever issues we
have, whatever we have,
just turn it into art
and coordinating it.
And I think that's
what the arts is about
is just putting that
all together and making
something remarkable out of it.
And it always starts
with the arts.
The civil rights
movement started
within the arts community.
The turning points
came from the artists.
So I always thought the
arts were essential.
And this movie definitely
reinforced that whole idea
that the arts can still
be a healing force
and definitely bring
people together.
Again, I love this movie.
I absolutely love the film.
JENNIFER WRIGHT: I'll just
tag on that, that I completely
agree.
And I was thinking about that on
my way over about civil rights,
in particular in
Vietnam, and all
the different social
movements that have really
built from the arts
and how this film takes
a humongous step forward.
And I just really loved it.
So thank you.
And then the other side, for
me, is also the less direct ways
that we see arts impact.
Like the other
work that you make,
Jeremy, and the work
that you're involved with
and a lot of the work that we're
involved with might be deemed
art for art's sake.
And sometimes that's
a real critique
in that that's not good
enough, particularly
in a really competitive
funding environment.
And so how do we grapple with
letting art hold all of that?
Some of it is really direct in
the way these kids are impacted
or the way the
artists are impacted,
the way a country is impacted.
And then the other ways that
art impacts our civic dialogues
in maybe less a political
way or social justice way.
And how do we hold both of those
in our cultural participation,
I guess.
JOSEPHINE DORADO:
Great, thank you.
I know that each
of our communities
very much addresses
marginalization in each way.
The artists in The Field
community, and the artists
in the BRC, and the
artists in Angola
are very much addressing
this kind of marginalization.
What kinds of specific
artists or projects
can you think of that
have dealt with adversity
particularly well, whether it's
through Sandy, or through 9/11,
or specific other cases?
JENNIFER WRIGHT:
I'll dive in on that.
For instance, Miguel Gutierrez
has a dance theater music
company called Miguel Gutierrez
and the Powerful People.
And it might be deemed,
particularly his work,
more art for art's
sake in that way.
But it is grappling with
issues, particularly
in queer culture, that are
really assertive, and really
vibrant, and really provocative.
And his work, from
my point of view,
it's not attacking
a specific thing
like AIDS, culture,
or gay marriage.
It's not political outrightly.
But through his art making
and through his performance,
you are called to respond.
You are called as a human
being to feel something
and then potentially
do something with that.
Or someone like
Mike Daisey, who's
more overt in terms of his
monologue work with Apple
and that work and sort of
pushing those boundaries.
I feel like we probably each
have hundreds of examples.
Those are just two that
were off the top of my head.
EARL DOUGLAS: We've done a bunch
of-- I hate the word tribute.
We've always done
retrospectives.
We've always targeted a
specific artist's work.
We did the civil rights song
book of Curtis Mayfield.
And in doing that, you
kind of address issues
that are very universal.
He had a song called
"This is My Country."
And when we did
that show, it took
on this whole other
different context,
because we had the immigration
debate going on in the country.
We've taken shows
overseas and done
salute to women songwriters,
who in general, especially
in rock 'n roll been very
marginalized and downplayed.
And then you realize,
their catalogs is as strong
as anybody's.
Vernon Reid, he did a suite.
He called it the 9/11 suite.
And it didn't address
9/11 directly.
But it kind of addressed
the aftermath of it.
I saw him do a couple
performances of it
with Living Colour
also as a solo artist.
And it was very, very powerful.
I think that's kind of where
you can approach an issue
or problem without actually
just making it a grand theme
and having certain songs,
take them into an entirely
different level and using it
as a totally different context.
So I think, with us, that's
always been a challenge as far
as, how do we present
or direct an issue
without really
politicizing it at all?
We've done two, we
might do a third,
we call it the Million Man Mosh.
And it kind of addresses
how young black men
are treated in the
criminal justice system.
But it's not direct.
One of our longtime
members, his son
is kind of going through
the criminal justice system.
And we were doing it
as benefits for him.
And it just took on this
whole other universal theme.
We didn't even realize it.
And I think that's
how you do it.
That's how you attack a problem.
You kind of, OK, we're
putting the same picture
in a different frame.
And I think that's how
you can approach it.
And that's how the
arts really can work.
JEREMY XIDO: I mean, I think
these are phenomenon examples.
I think there are
lots and lots and lots
of artists that are out
there working in this way.
There's a whole genre of art
that I'm particularly fond of.
And it just happens.
It's urban graffiti
art, which I actually
don't know who does it other
than-- I know people by tags.
But the reason why I'm
particularly drawn to it,
and I actually see when
thinking about the film
and thinking about Okutiuka,
we paid special attention
to the walls in the space.
And one of the reasons is that,
they're around you everywhere.
And in the walls, there's
something about history
that's inscribed in it.
So there's time.
There's decay.
There's the war.
There's bullet holes and things.
But then there's also the
faded paintings that exist
and the story of Yakuza,
who's a young kid who died,
who they got to
draw on the walls
and get everybody
else to draw on.
The thing about it
is there's something
about inscribing
something in space.
And at that point, you've
changed the environment.
And you've established
some form of history.
And so a story is then told out
of that moment, which everybody
has to know, because
it's where they live.
And you know the
story about that.
And there's a kind
of politicization
and a validation of
self and a community.
And I find that graffiti
art actually establishes
a broader community of people
who are not necessarily artists
but are people.
And that link, at least
from where I come from,
that graffiti is really big
and seeing it in this space,
I would say all the
graffiti artists out
in the world, most of them.
JENNIFER WRIGHT: Can I
just add something to that?
JOSEPHINE DORADO: Sure.
JENNIFER WRIGHT: I was
thinking about your question
about marginalization and
then those kids in the film,
particularly what
you said earlier
about giving opportunities,
particularly for music, as such
an outlet for storytelling.
And one of things in terms
of marginalized folks,
even here in the States it's
quite different from Angola,
obviously, but who
gets to be an artist?
Who gets those
opportunities, whether that's
funding in the schools
or the price of an MFA,
or equipment to try
and play guitar,
or all of that stuff,
who gets to do that?
And I am more and more
concerned about that.
I call it the art gap,
for lack of a better word.
Who is getting to do this?
And is it skewing more
and more towards income
privileged folks, primarily
white folks in this country,
or whatever it is?
Where is that skewing?
And who are we losing?
And all the beautiful
making that we're losing,
whether it's quote
unquote "professional"
or not, what you
can do with that
as a human being just
given the opportunity.
There's an organization called
Willie Mae Girls Rock Camp.
EARL DOUGLAS: Rock
camp for girls.
JENNIFER WRIGHT: Unbelievable.
And I did their Ladies
Rock Camp twice.
And that's for
resilience building.
It saved my life as
the executive director
of a nonprofit.
But the rock camp is, it's
unbelievable what they offer.
And in terms of gender
issues and sexuality issues
and then music as
an empowerment tool.
And more and more
concerned in this country
about where are we investing.
Where are we
investing, particularly
in kids and who
we're going to lose.
JOSEPHINE DORADO:
Great, thank you.
So those were all really
great jumping off points.
And so I want to sort
of wrap this up and take
any questions, or
feedback, or comments
that we might have from
people in the audience.
So I feel like I see
one hand out there.
There's that mic and
that mic on that side.
So if anyone wants
to jump up, Shemaine.
JENNIFER WRIGHT:
Don't be afraid.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jeremy
and everybody else.
I really enjoyed the film.
And I really found the
people just so amazing,
especially the people
running the orphanage.
Can you tell us more
about how you met them
and how you got involved
in making this film?
JEREMY XIDO: Yeah, well, there's
a pat story by now that I tell.
So I'll just tell it.
It was by accident.
I met them totally by accident.
I was in Angola filming a
completely different movie
about Chinese construction
workers that are rebuilding
the train line that cuts
through the middle of Angola.
And the train line just
stops in this town, Huambo.
And I had got out and I wanted
a cup of coffee really badly.
And there's apparently
only one place
in the entire town that
serves a decent cup of coffee.
It's called Imperial.
So I went there.
And when I was there, I
sat down with my coffee
and some guy across the way
was like, he waved me over.
And I kind of went over.
I was like, OK.
And I brought my little
coffee and stuff with him.
It's like, hey,
what are you doing?
And we talked.
And he asked me what I did.
I said I was making a movie.
That's great, what do you do?
He's like, oh, I'm a musician.
That's really cool.
What do you play?
Death metal.
And I was floored.
I said, you what?
And I said, well,
can you play for me?
He's like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
Listen, here.
Here's my telephone number and
meet me tonight at this address
at the orphanage,
which I assumed at
that point was a club.
And I invited the Chinese
construction workers
that I had been filming
and working with
to go see this concert
out at the orphanage.
And so we drove in their SUV.
And we arrived to
this neighborhood.
And it just happened
to be on a night
where the generator was out.
And there was no electricity.
And so Wilker was there sort
of siphoning electricity
from his neighbor to
plug-in his amplifier.
And there were no lights.
There was no microphone.
And so we lit it with
the lights of the SUV.
And he proceeded to
play the single most
harrowing and beautiful open
air concert I've ever heard.
And there were these shadows of
kids running around everywhere.
And I had no idea
what was going on.
And these people became
dear, dear friends.
And about a year later,
we were going back to film
the train film.
And I called up Wilker, and
by that time I had met Sonia,
and said we're coming back.
I would love to see you
if your around and film.
They're like oh, my god.
That's great that you're
coming, because we're organizing
the first ever
national rock concert
and you're going to film it.
And that was it.
I was hired at that moment.
And that's it.
That's how it happened.
And it built over a course
of a couple of years.
And it was a partnership,
really, between us
and the Association for
Angolan Rock as a friendship
partnership.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: A
lovely happy accident.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
again for this film.
It's really amazing.
Is it open to the public?
Where can you see this film now?
JEREMY XIDO: I'll
answer that one.
Sorry, guys.
The film premiered at the
beginning of the year.
And it's been on the
international festival circuit.
So it's traveled
around the country
to maybe 30 festivals, 30,
40 festivals worldwide,
every continent
except for Antarctica.
And it is going make its New
York debut on November 16
at the Doc NYC festival
here in New York.
And we're currently working
with the Fulbright Association
on organizing a tour of the
film through the United States
that we're calling the DMA
Resilience tour, which we're
looking to launch in
spring 2014 to cities
around the country like Detroit,
where I'm from, or New Orleans,
or a whole slew of others
that have been hit hard
by economic or a
natural disaster.
And we're going to have
a series of screenings,
town hall conversations about
resilience, and local concerts.
And so we're about to start a
fund raising campaign for that
and get that off and running.
So ideally in the spring, it'll
be much more widely accessible.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: Great.
So just to wrap it up,
I think we actually
have to get things moving.
Just a few last words on--
oh, there's one last question.
Yeah?
OK, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
for Earl, actually.
I just was really
struck by your feeling
familiar with the folks in
the film about the early days
of the Black Rock Coalition.
And now that you're
25 years in, I
wonder if there's
advice for them.
Or if there's a
way that you feel
like how they're beginning to
gel is really going to stick
and how you can imagine for
them where the future might go.
EARL DOUGLAS: Advice
is just keep going.
A, key playing.
Just that little
epilogue at the end
was very encouraging
as well that they
were able to do it a year later.
And it was bigger.
And it was clearly more
concise and more organized.
Like the first one, the
sound wasn't working.
The show started
five hours late.
And this wasn't working.
And that wasn't working.
And yet, they
pulled the show off.
And my advice would
be just keep going,
find ways to make it better.
And just let the scene
kind of go where it goes.
Don't try to shape it anyway.
Wherever it goes, let it go.
I mean, that would be my advice.
And the chief advice
would be just keep going.
Just keep following the art.
It will not betray you.
JEREMY XIDO: That's great.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: Just put one
foot in front of the other,
keep going.
So what are some last
words that you might all
have on how we as communities
can support artists
so that artists can
support their communities?
JENNIFER WRIGHT: I'll be direct.
Go to shows.
I have three.
Go to shows, join a board
of an organization you love,
and give them money.
So shows, boards, and money.
Sort of back to where are
we going as a country,
the marketplace has
gotten so competitive
and questions all the time
about what kind of ROI
does art give in the
world, and concerns
about new money versus old
money and all of these things.
And art, I think if we
commit to it as a people,
like what we believe
and what we want
to see, we have to
put money behind that,
and time behind that,
and volunteer hours.
If you believe in
it, then go do it.
EARL DOUGLAS: I'm kind
of echoing her statement.
Support it with your dollars.
Support it with your
presence, mainly.
Because especially
here in New York,
it's tough to get-- it's weird.
And now we're in this kind
of internet computer age,
it's harder and harder to
get people to actually leave
their computer to go to a show.
Support the shows.
Support organizations that
support artists or support
the nurturing of artists,
especially with young people.
I always say, have an open mind.
I think the biggest
obstacle that we've always
faced with the Black Rock
Coalition has always been,
I don't like that rock thing.
It's like, have
you listened to it,
like really broken down
and listened to it?
And they go no.
It's like, maybe you should.
Have a better understanding
of its history.
Because for me,
everything connects.
Which is why I like
every kind of music,
because I think it all connects
in some way or another.
There's a connect between
Louis Jordan and Snoop Dogg.
So educate yourself on
top of everything else.
But support the arts.
Whether it's the Willie Mae
Rock Camp, or it's the BRC,
whatever, you support it with
presence and with your dollars.
I mean, that's the short answer.
JEREMY XIDO: It's funny.
Because what both
of you are saying
is exactly what people in Angola
are saying about their worlds.
It's the same issues.
The only thing I would add
to it maybe is to make stuff,
is to be creatively engaged
in the conversation.
And ultimately I see it as
a conversation or something
about consuming, the way
that people go see shows
if you have a good
time or whatever.
And there's another
thing about if it's
your people in some way or the
people that you've committed to
or the thing that you
yourself have gone out to do.
And then there's something
about actually creating
a world in which you
actually just do shit.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: I
would add to that, too.
And this sort of
goes on what Earl
was saying about
having an open mind
is that having an open mind
with regards to what art is
and how we as communities
can support art,
so whether that's opening up
different kinds of revenue
models, looking at different
kinds of crowd funding
campaigns, or just being
inventive in the way
that we, as artists look at
our art as an entrepreneurship,
and as a business,
and how we could
look at hybrid models of
how to do those things.
As Jeremy mentioned before,
the Fulbright New York chapter
is also helping out with
doing this crowd funding
campaign of the Resilience
tour, which we're launching
on RocketHub in
the next few days.
So look for the Resilience
Tour on RocketHub.
But very much around the whole
conversation of opening up what
we envision as art and as
community and community
development.
JEREMY XIDO: If I
can just add to that.
I think one of the
really interesting things
about the crowd funding
model is the notion
that it's about democratizing
funding on the one hand.
But it seems to me
that it's even more so
about establishing community
using the internet age
or in the place,
how do you actually
get into different communities
and have people invest not
just financially but
invest emotionally
and creatively in a
project so that they
become part of that project.
How do you become part
of the Resilience Tour?
JOSEPHINE DORADO: How do
we make stuff together?
JEREMY XIDO: How do you do shit?
JOSEPHINE DORADO: How
do you do shit together?
EARL DOUGLAS: Yeah, just to
add on to that, Fishbone,
long time BRC supporter
band, their last album
was crowd funded.
And they had a great line.
It was, you are the
producer of the record.
And I thought that's
a pretty easy way
to make people understand
what this means.
It's like, you know what, I'm
producing the album of the band
that I always loved.
And I think it becomes
very empowering.
And I think that's
a very key part of,
I guess, with crowd funding
that kind of gets lost.
You know what, you're
being part of this project
that you always wanted to see.
God knows we hear enough
about stuff that's out there.
And it's being
consumed by the masses.
And everyone's like
this sucks and how
come people are buying it?
People are buying it because
people are supporting it.
Somebody's buying it.
And you could do the same thing.
It's like, OK, don't
complain about it.
Do something about it.
Put your dollars behind it.
And I think, again, it has
to be stressed over and over
and over again.
Whatever project you're
passionate about, whatever
artists, whatever you're
into, if you don't
put the time into it,
if you don't nurture it,
it's not going to go to where
you think you want it to go.
JENNIFER WRIGHT: Can
I just tag on maybe
as a Debbie Downer for a second,
just on the crowd funding?
One thing we see a lot with
our 1,400 artists, the crowd
funding certain
models also really
not just encourage but
urge you to give away
stuff for your dollar.
So if I give $25,
I'll get two tickets
to a show and a signed album
and a dinner with Jeremy.
And suddenly the $25 is
really worth so much more.
And it kind of speaks
to the ROI thing.
What is philanthropy
in this day and age?
And what do we expect?
And a lot of the
artists we see are just
giving away so much stuff, in
part because they don't believe
that the experiment and the
art itself is sufficient.
So they're going to give
you a mug, and a tote bag,
and a happy ending, everything.
They're going to give away the
store in order to get your $25.
And we just really try
and work with our folks
at least, just be
cognizant of that.
One, can you handle it?
Can handle giving
away all that stuff?
What does that mean in terms
of investors, and backers,
and all of that?
What does that mean?
Are there people who
really are OK with,
let me just give you some money,
because philanthropically I
believe in the importance
of what you're doing.
And that's awesome.
So just to be
strategic about that.
And if, for instance, I give
money to WNYC, and I say
I don't want this stuff.
I don't need this stuff.
I believe in WNYC.
I don't need the tote bag.
I don't need "The New
Yorker," which I can't even
read because there's too many
of them, despite the fact
that I love it.
But I don't need it,
just take my money.
JOSEPHINE DORADO: All
right, thank you all.
Thank you for your
time and your feedback.
And thank you all for your
time and your feedback, too.
JEREMY XIDO: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]